[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrar
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
los socios díscolos de la unión europea
nos referimos a polonia y hungría
conmigo en este estudio eulalia rubio
investigadora en el instituto jacques
delors especialista en asuntos
económicos europeos bienvenida al
allianz de leer una tele y periodista
independiente bienvenida a delia y en
dúplex desde bruselas la corresponsal de
rfi de france24 esther herrera esther
buenos días buenos dias los incómodos
socios del este hoy nuestro asunto en
primera plana
[Música]
el pulso entre la unión europea y
polonia y hungría sigue de plena
actualidad y no todos los socios del
bloque coinciden en cómo actuar varsovia
se ha rebelado contra la justicia
europea el constitucional polaco declara
que varios artículos de los tratados de
la unión europea son incompatibles con
la ley fundamental del país tesis que
comparte el gobierno polaco pero aquí no
acaba todo porque las batallas entre la
unión europea y los díscolos vecinos del
este a cuenta de los valores centrales
del bloque comunitario son varias la
independencia de los jueces los derechos
lgtb y e incluso la sombra de corrupción
sobre el presidente húngaro viktor orbán
los gobiernos ultra conservadores y
soberanistas de varsovia budapest tienen
una crisis abierta desde hace tiempo con
la unión europea por sus políticas
autoritarias y homófobas y hoy lo vamos
a analizar antes de ello como siempre
repasemos algunas portadas desde polonia
a gazeta wyborcza el primer ministro
polaco matheus maravilla que intenta
convencer al parlamento europeo que el
estado de derecho y la democracia en
polonia están fuera de duda en alemania
el frankfurter allgemeine zeitung
titulaba políticos europeos insisten en
mano dura contra polonia y la revista
newsweek llegó a bautizar al presidente
húngaro en 2018 a orbán como mister far
right míster extrema derecha bueno la
aliá europa tiene un verdadero problema
con los vecinos díscolos del este si
tiene un verdadero problema y es quizás
una de las crisis más importantes de
hecho las otras crisis que hemos tenido
siempre crisis migratoria crisis
económicas hay una posible solución
siempre podemos poner dinero podemos
relanzar la economía en este caso es una
que es una crisis que toca el núcleo
duro de lo que es la construcción
europea que es una construcción basada
en el estado de derecho y en las leyes y
es de difícil solución también ya
hablaremos de esto durante la durante la
misión un verdadero problema totalmente
porque se trata de definir qué
que el discurso nacional de estos países
no venga en contra del discurso que
representa la unión europea poner los
límites nunca es fácil vamos a ver cómo
se ataja esto porque parece que la una
europea va ataca polonia y hungría donde
más les duele en el bolsillo no sé qué
esta presión se puede dar frutos y bueno
ahí esta idea de que vamos a cortar los
fondos europeos para intentar solucionar
estos problemas y realmente es
importante intentarlo es son dos países
que son de los de los que benefician más
de los fondos europeos es verdad que
puede hacer mucho daño pero es una
solución que también tiene peligro
porque al final lo que estás atacando
los que van a perder en eso son los
beneficiarios finales de estos fondos
europeos las pequeñas y medianas
empresas los agricultores las
universidades es decir que es una
solución potente pero que tiene
problemas también vamos a que nos lo
explique desde bruselas nuestra
corresponsal esther herrera lo primero
es ver qué hay detrás del pulso del que
tanto hablamos entre la unión europea y
polonia
hace 5 años cuando el actual gobierno
del partido ultraderechista la ley
injusticia tomó el poder en polonia
empezó una reforma judicial que contiene
varias leyes una de las principales es
que básicamente el ministerio de
justicia puede decidir quiénes deben ser
los jueces y también quién puede
destituirlos además también creó una
sala disciplinaria que sirve para
castigar los jueces en casos de abuso de
poder pero lo que teme bruselas es que
está este órgano lo que hará es purgar a
magistrados que no son afines al
gobierno esta es la ley por la que la
justicia europea exige una multa de un
millón de euros diaria por cada día que
no se cancele este órgano y una ley que
adelanta la jubilación de los jueces
pudiendo así renovar casi un tercio del
tribunal supremo y así el ejecutivo
tener vía libre para nombrar los
magistrados que quiera esto es lo que
preocupa a bruselas porque pone en
peligro la independencia judicial esa
multa de un millón euros que la
conocíamos durante esta pasada de esta
semana a partir de ahí y tras la cumbre
europea de la semana pasada
de posturas de los socios respecto a qué
sanciones hasta que el nivel a aplicar
que puede hacerla un europea este
recortar ayudas y fondos a un país que
reciben mucho desde bruselas existen
varias opciones una es la activación del
conocido como artículo 7 del tratado que
se trata de un proceso bastante largo
que a un país se le puede dejar sin voto
las decisiones que toman los países este
artículo ya está activado con polonia de
hecho pero para que pueda entrar en
vigor se necesita la unanimidad de todos
los países y como hungría apoya polonia
esto nunca se ha producido la otra
opción es la congelación de los fondos
europeos como los fondos de cohesión que
sirven para mejorar el desarrollo del
país esta congelación de fondos se
podría hacer a través de los
presupuestos europeos pero actualmente
se está pendiente de que la justicia
europea decida si este mecanismo es
legal o no y en función de ello la
comisión decidirá finalmente está la
opción de que no se entregue no se
entregue el dinero del fondo de
recuperación
polonia tiene pendiente de recibir unos
36 mil millones de euros existen varias
opciones
bueno pues ambos gobiernos varsovia
budapest culpan a una europea de estar
extorsionando les y en cierta forma
bueno esto es un poco lo que está
ocurriendo no es decir tocar el bolsillo
del activa definitivamente pero creo que
la unión europea no tenía otra opción no
podía seguir
permitiendo las leyes que se están
adoptando tanto en unidad y sobre todo
en uría y en polonia al dejar pasar
estas leyes y no poner ningún tipo de
sanción
certera era aceptar esta corriente como
parte de la unión europea es riesgoso
porque no se sabe qué va a pasar no se
sabe si eso va a acrecentar la brecha
este-oeste o si va a dar algún tipo de
resultado más positivo diálogo un
diálogo real no solamente el discurso
vamos a explicar ambos cursos por
separado separando ahora polonia de
hungría porque muchos polacos pro
europeos han salido estos días a
protestar a las calles explicando que
quieren seguir en europa la pregunta que
quizás se hagan nuestros oyentes y
telespectadores es que hace un país tan
europeísta según los sondeos como
polonia votando gobiernos que toman
derivas como la reforma de los jueces
contrarias al espíritu europeo una
pregunta muy lógica es verdad que
polonia y hungría son casos distintos en
muchos muchas dimensiones y por ejemplo
entre otras por ejemplo en polonia
tenemos el pis en el gobierno pero está
en coalición no tienen no tienen la
posición dominante que tiene fides de
órgano en hungría y lo vemos porque por
ejemplo vemos manifestaciones contra el
pis que no vemos en hungría cuando hay
problemas de este tipo entonces es
verdad que es un país muy europeísta
pero también es verdad que es un país
una visión bastante instrumental de la
unión europea y europeísta porque ha
recibido también muchos fondos europeos
cuando hablamos con expertos polacos nos
dicen que no tienen este nivel de
relación con la unión europea de los
valores que hay en otros países entonces
hay que ver lo que pasará pero yo creo
que en parte el hecho de que la
población sale salga a la calle también
también refleja el hecho de que en el
fondo aunque el gobierno de morávek y
este con esta con esta batalla con la
unión europea tienen en el fondo la
convicción de que al final los fondos
europeos van a llegar porque el impacto
sería muy muy importante si no llegan a
estos fondos y videos contra hungría el
pulso tiene que ver tanto con una
polémica ley anti lgtb que limita a los
mayores de 18 años los contenidos que
abordan cuestiones sobre el género que
se alejen de las visiones del gobierno
húngaro qué visión tiene viktor orbán de
las políticas de género y por qué de una
amenaza constante en el momento el gp
tiene visión bien reducida porque las
asocia más a una ideología que a una a
una ciencia para comenzar dice él lo
asocia con el comunismo
mismo es como si una preferencia sexual
fuera más de índole ideológica yo creo
que es la construcción nacional que se
apoya directamente que el gobierno se
apoyó directamente una sociedad
tradicional
ligada a la religión católica que desea
estandarizar un poco las costumbres
nacionales yo creo que ese tipo de
partidos se crean más más que nada de la
extrema derecha en oposición a no a
favor de entonces en oposición a la
ideología de género él se está oponiendo
a ello no está donde la solución
solamente es una en oposición pero
contrapuso a pensarlas también hay otro
punto distinto bligh el que tiene que
ver con la corrupción que afecta
directamente a los fondos europeos que
durante años han servido para que el
primer ministro victor victor orbán haya
ido tejiendo digamos una red clientelar
clientelar a su alrededor como como ha
sido este proceso de creación de esta
red de orbán es para que hace años que
tenemos un problema con eso y en cierta
medida ha habido una negligencia de la
parte de la comisión de no suspender
fondos antes había muchos índices de que
había esta red clientelar y esta
historia lización un poco fraudulenta de
los fondos europeos sólo un dato en este
sentido el 40 por ciento de contratación
pública en hungría de fondos europeos
sólo tiene una empresa que se presenta
en la contratación pública es decir es
realmente un dato que nos que nos
demuestra que algo no va bien la agencia
que coordina la contratación pública en
hungría ya había sido identificada por
la comisión como una agencia muy
politizada y que tenía problemas y hace
tiempo ya que se pedía hungría que
hiciera reformas en este sentido pero
nunca se han atrevido hasta ahora a
cortar los fondos europeos igual es
ahora el momento de empezar a ser un
poco más fuerte en este sentido trabajo
quizá la pregunta es por qué es que
ahora europa ha tardado tanto en pararle
los pies a radio había también una
ausencia de instrumentos para hacerlo es
verdad que ahora están por ejemplo
intentando poner en marcha esta
condicionalidad estado de derecho que
permitirá a la comisión más fácilmente
suspender fondos antes no teníamos este
mecanismo que en principio tiene que
estar y activado a finales de año y la
comisión tenía siempre que recabar
evidencias y pruebas muy claras de que
había ido un pedido un problema de
utilización fraudulenta del fondo cosa
que a veces es difícil cuando los fondos
son se
gastan a nivel nacional es difícil para
la comisión tenerlas los datos las
evidencias para poder suspender los
fondos que le voy a preguntar
precisamente esther herrera que
posiciones hay dentro del seno de la
unión europea sobre cómo tratar en
general a los incómodos socios tanto a
polonia como hungría esther no se suele
poner en el mismo saco aunque polonia en
cuanto a los bandos pero sí que es
verdad que hay una parte que apuesta más
por una mano más dura con estos países
sobre todo los demás de corte liberal
como países bajos luxemburgo bélgica y
otros que quieren en cambio evitar la
completación como por ejemplo alemania
es cierto que se ha hecho mucho la vista
gorda con los dos países con hungría en
2010 por ejemplo cuando el primer
ministro del país viktor orbán llegó al
poder y empezó su deriva autoritaria y
fue muy difícil de explicar pero aún así
se le consintió mucho su partido el
fidesz estuvo hasta hace muy poco en el
grupo mayoritario de la eurocámara el
partido popular europeo y en parte mucho
ha sido gracias angela merkel que hasta
ahora ha evitado tanto la confrontación
con estos países que muchos se han
sentido impunes pero desde que viktor
orbán ha mantenido esta deriva cada vez
estaba más solo y esto se hizo muy
patente por ejemplo la reunión de
líderes europeos del pasado junio a
causa de su polémica ley sobre la
infancia que llegaba a relacionar ser
homosexual con la pederastia y esto ha
sido una línea roja para muchos países
que fueron muy duros contra orbán con
polonia aunque hay tensiones y le ha
dejado también hacer mucho polonia tiene
en cambio un mayor peso en la unión
europea que hungría también es un país
mucho más grande y angela merkel incluso
la última reunión siguió insistiendo en
el diálogo porque no quiere molestar
tampoco demasiado polonia que ya está
suficientemente molesta a causa del
gasoducto nord stream 2 e insiste en que
hay que hablar pero lo cierto es que es
un diálogo de sordos
ya ven qué interesante todo lo que nos
está contando esther herrera desde
bruselas hacemos en este punto una breve
pausa pero enseguida volvemos aquí en
primera plana para seguir hablando de
polonia y hungría los socios díscolos de
la unión europea
[Música]
y
inicio en italia la cumbre del g20 el
primer encuentro presencial de los
líderes de las principales economías del
mundo gira en torno a temas como el
logro de 'cero emisiones' la
recuperación económica global y el
acceso a vacunas en países con bajos
recursos
todo listo en glasgow escocia para el
inicio de la cumbre climática con 26
mañana el encuentro es considerado la
oportunidad definitiva para que los
países demuestren su verdadero
compromiso en la lucha contra el cambio
climático seis años después de suscribir
el acuerdo de parís a su vez hoy
finaliza oficialmente el encuentro de
jóvenes por el clima
se agudiza la crisis diplomática entre
el humano y arabia saudita riad ordenó
la expulsión en un plazo de 48 horas del
representante diplomático libanés y
llamó a su embajador en beirut luego de
que el ministro libanés de información
criticar a la coalición militar que
lidera la arabia saudita contra los
rebeldes yemeníes desde 2015
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan las jornadas fue
valentina torre sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos damos inicio en italia
comenzó en roma la cumbre del g20 los
jefes de estado y de gobierno que
asisten al primer encuentro presencial
de las 20 mayores economías del planeta
desde el inicio de la pandemia se
enfrentan a una serie de problemas en
primer lugar de la agenda están la
recuperación económica y la crisis
climática una preocupación que se
intensifica a vísperas de la cob 26 pues
se teme que no todos los mandatarios
estén de acuerdo en la manera de
afrontar lo que se ha descrito como una
amenaza existencial para toda la
humanidad
arranca el g20 en roma en medio de
tensiones entre los asistentes a la
cumbre que parece no estar en sintonía
ante múltiples retos y si
vemos niveles peligrosos de desconfianza
entre las grandes potencias entre los
miembros del g20 entre los países
desarrollados y los países en desarrollo
incluidas las economías emergentes el
objetivo más importante de esta cumbre
del g20 debe ser restablecer la
confianza abordando las principales
fuentes de desconfianza enraizadas en
las injusticias las desigualdades y las
divisiones geopolíticas este tipo de
confianza será vital para tratar los
temas urgentes que se tienen entre manos
recuperación tras la pandemia de
coronavirus y sus consecuencias
económicas así como concretar los planes
para hacer frente a la crisis climática
sin embargo los mandatarios xi jinping
de china y vladimir putin de rusia no
asistirán en persona un posible mensaje
de que las preocupaciones internas han
ganado la partida un punto positivo
podría ser la finalización de un acuerdo
para impuestos global mínimo sobre las
grandes corporaciones no se ha avanzado
mucho en la lucha contra la pandemia en
un frente común las críticas no se
limitan a que los países desarrollados
proporcionan suficientes vacunas a los
países más pobres sino por el
incumplimiento de las promesas de ayuda
de más de 100 mil millones de dólares al
año para ayudar a esos mismos países a
hacer frente a lo que podría ser la
preocupación más urgente del g20 la
crisis climática
ha sido este es el momento de hacerlo
realmente es el momento para el dinero
dinero dinero es el momento de cumplir
promesas han prometido que realmente
harán su parte en la búsqueda de esta
base de 100 mil millones de dólares por
año para ayudar a las naciones pobres en
su lucha y empuje para el cambio
climático eso no ha ocurrido
en japón los miembros del g20 son
responsables del 80 por ciento de las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
del mundo y justo antes de la cumbre
climática con 26 en reino unido- la
atención se centrará en roma durante el
fin de semana en busca de cualquier
señal de que el mundo pueda finalmente
ponerse en marcha para cumplir los
objetivos de reducción de emisiones en
el plazo previsto
faltan menos de 24 horas para la
conferencia de las naciones unidas sobre
el cambio climático con 26 en donde los
países buscarán compromisos para
revertir la crisis climática a
continuación les presentamos un recuento
de las naciones más golpeadas por las
emergencias en la última década ciclones
tormentas y huracanes son solo algunos
de los fenómenos que causaron más
estragos en diferentes partes del mundo
manuel acá no tiene los detalles
más letal que las guerras o las
enfermedades el cambio climático deja su
huella en 2008 2.4 millones de personas
fueron desplazadas por una tormenta en
mianmar 17 veces más que las
desaparecidas y fallecidas en medio de
la conmoción social que vivía el país
uno de los países más afectados en la
última década en el caribe ha sido haití
las inundaciones que provocó el huracán
sand y acabaron con cerca de 70 vidas
humanas
el huracán maría azotó a puerto rico el
20 de septiembre de 2017 destruyendo
carreteras y puentes y fue la tormenta
más poderosa que haya tocado la isla
dejando 2 mil 975 muertos el continente
africano se vio tocado por el fuerte
ciclón y dady en 2019 provocando la
muerte de mil personas en mozambique
zimbabwe y malawi el mismo año pero al
otro lado del mundo en las bahamas el
huracán dorian lo catalogaron como el
más intenso en la historia de la isla
llegando a las costas estadounidenses un
tiempo después y provocando la
evacuación de más de un millón de
personas en 2019 6 de los 10 países más
afectados por la crisis medioambiental
fueron azotados por ciclones el año
pasado las lluvias tocaron a múltiples
países a lo largo del mundo pakistán
registró una temporada de monzones que
causaron más de 4.000 muertes y 200.000
viviendas fueron destruidas también en
nepal las tormentas provocaron
inundaciones y deslizamientos dejando
132 fallecidos y millones de desplazados
2020 fue uno de los tres años más
calurosos registrados con temperaturas
promedio globales de 1.2 grados
centígrados por encima de la época
preindustrial mientras tanto los
expertos alertan que los ciclones
tropicales aumentarán debido a la subida
de la temperatura global vamos ahora
hasta el líbano donde se agudiza la
crisis diplomática con arabia saudita
real llamó a su embajador en beirut y
expulsó a su homólogo en territorio
saudita luego de que el ahora ministro
de información libanés criticar a la
coalición militar que lidera a arabia
saudita contra los rebeldes útiles en
yemen desde la capital libanesa nuestra
corresponsal etel bonet nos cuenta más
a las múltiples crisis que atraviesa el
líbano se suma ahora una crisis
diplomática con los países del golfo
después de que anoche arabia saudi haya
llamado a su embajador a retirarse en 48
horas y prohibiera a la exportación de
todos los productos y a sus ciudadanos
viajar a líbano el incidente diplomático
fue provocado por unas declaraciones del
ministro de información afín al partido
hezbollah que hace unos meses dijo en
una radio pública saudí que los útiles
tenían el derecho a defenderse si
estaban siendo atacados cabe recordar
que arabia saudi lidera una coalición
que está luchando contra los rebeldes
hutíes en el yemen desde 2015 siguiendo
a la decisión de riad también el reino
de baherin ha llamado a su embajador a
retirarse y ha cortado las exportaciones
el líbano importa prácticamente todos
sus productos alimenticios por lo que
esta medida afectará todavía más la vida
de los libaneses que ya están sufriendo
de una escasez de alimentos de medicinas
y también de falta de leche que más que
falta de electricidad es una ausencia
total ya que cortes de luz más de 20
horas diarias a esta nueva crisis
diplomática con los países del golfo ha
provocado una agitación política y ha
llevado a los partidos de la oposición a
pedir la dimisión del primer ministro
nayib mitaki el depuesto gobierno
sudanés advirtió este sábado que usar la
violencia en las grandes protestas
convocadas contra el golpe de estado
será contraproducente para los militares
ya iniciaron las movilizaciones que se
espera sean multitudinarias en jartúm la
capital del país por lo que el ejecutivo
disuelto tras el golpe de estado pidió a
las fuerzas armadas y a los servicios de
seguridad que frenen la violencia al
menos 11 personas han perdido la vida en
medio de protestas durante la última
semana
eeuu hizo un llamado a respetar los
derechos humanos en el país
este 31 de octubre japón acudirá a las
urnas en la primera prueba real para el
nuevo primer ministro fumio kishida
algunos analistas creen que la
participación podría caer por debajo del
50% por primera vez la manera de
convencer a los votantes indiferentes
indecisos o simplemente enojados es un
gran desafío para los partidos japoneses
incluido el partido liberal democrático
que ha gobernado casi
ininterrumpidamente desde mediados de la
década de 1950
a pesar de ser candidata por primera vez
en las elecciones de la cámara baja de
japón moto con mis uno ve lo difícil que
es convencer a los votantes indiferentes
buenos días soy moto com/issue no estoy
obligada a presentarme primero la gente
tiene que saber qué tipo de persona soy
mucha gente va a trabajar en el metro
así que vine a la estación para
saludarlos los candidatos recorren sus
distritos electorales repitiendo
consignas a través de un altavoz como
madre soltera los antecedentes de mizuno
se consideran un obstáculo para ganar un
escaño en el parlamento de japón las
mujeres representan sólo el 10 por
ciento de los legisladores en la cámara
baja
establecer un sistema de cuotas nos
permitiría lograr la igualdad de género
al menos en la política me temo que sin
eso las mujeres no estarán mejor
representadas
la apatía de muchos votantes es un
obstáculo para el cambio con el
parlamento dominado por hombres este
politólogo cree que los factores
culturales tienen mucho que ver
si incita a la gente a pensar que es
mejor mantener un perfil bajo conseguir
buenos trabajos en lugar de intentar
cambiar la sociedad a través de la
acción política sienten que no tiene
sentido invertir tiempo y energía en
construir una alternativa al gobierno
actual
algunas encuestas sugieren que el
partido liberal-democrático perderá
escaños pero mantendrá su mayoría aunque
si la participación es tan baja algunos
se preguntan si contará con el apoyo del
pueblo japonés
en eeuu la autoridad de medicamentos y
alimentos a utilizar o autorizo casi de
forma unánime que la vacuna the fighter
by ontex sea aplicada a niños entre 5 y
11 años la dosis que se les administrará
será inferior a la de los adultos para
evitar que los efectos secundarios sean
fuertes andrés granadillo no es amplia
luz verde para la vacuna de facer
variante que niños la decisión fue
tomada de forma abrumadora por la
administración de alimentos y
medicamentos de eeuu
efe
así que esto concluye la votación de los
18 miembros 17 votaron a favor y uno se
abstuvo de hardware en unos 28 millones
de niños estadounidenses entre 5 y 11
años que están regresando a clases
presenciales son elegibles para
aplicarse esta vacuna contra el cob y 19
según estudios clínicos de la
farmacéutica la vacuna tiene una
eficacia del 97 por ciento es la primera
en ser aprobada por eeuu para esta
población solo china cuba y los emiratos
árabes unidos han avalado vacunar a los
niños de estas edades claro si será la
tercera parte de la que se usa para los
adultos ya que según los expertos una
dosis más baja puede ayudar a que los
raros efectos secundarios sean menos
fuertes serán también dos dosis
aplicadas con tres semanas de diferencia
aunque aún falta que sea aprobada por
los centros para el control y la
prevención de enfermedades
ellos tienen previsto reunirse la
próxima semana y para mí la cuestión es
muy clara no queremos que los niños
mueran por él covite incluso si son
menos niños que adultos y no los
queremos en la uci pero las tasas de
vacunación en eeuu no son las mejores
del mundo el 58% de los ciudadanos de
este país se han vacunado completamente
en comparación con francia o reino unido
donde han alcanzado a inmunizar a más
del 70% de la población el pasado 26 de
octubre ya un panel de consejeros de la
actual administración de la casa blanca
había recomendado la autorización de la
vacuna para los menores la autorización
no garantiza que muchos padres lleven a
sus hijos a los centros de vacunación
vamos ahora a la isla española de la
palma donde esta mañana se registró un
sismo de 5,1 grados a 39 kilómetros de
profundidad se trata del movimiento
telúrico más fuerte desde que inició la
erupción del volcán cumbre vieja y de
acuerdo con expertos indica que nuevos
flujos de magma están abriendo paso
hacia la superficie lo que significa que
el volcán sigue altamente activo
y finalizamos en francia donde se lleva
a cabo el salón del chocolate el evento
más grande del mundo dedicado al cacao y
sus derivados desde versalles nuestra
periodista natalia ruiz nos dio más
detalles de esta muestra el chocolate se
toma parís por espacio de un fin de
semana la idea de este salón es la de
caminar entre los cientos de stands que
muestran las diferentes preparaciones
los diferentes tipos de chocolate
algunas incluso de con sabores bastante
particulares pero más allá de esto
también se trata de un viaje a través
del mundo de quienes lo preparan la
característica de este cacao chuncho y
los granos de cacao es que incluso se
pueden consumir lo que se conoce como el
huevo cacao el cacao crudo sin tostar y
para ello yo les puedo hacer una
demostración simplemente se se quita
la cáscara
yo puedo comérmelo y disfrutar
cuando usted prueba el chocolate a la
primera probada usted dice guau qué es
esto porque no es amargo incluso a veces
la gente me pregunta si esto de
chocolate o si este yo les digo no el
chocolate pero hay una manera especial
de cocinarlo además de las degustaciones
y de los diferentes concursos la idea de
este salón también es demostrar que el
chocolate es algo muy noble con el cual
además pueden incluso hacerse obras de
arte hay varias esculturas en diferentes
stands de animales incluso de gárgolas
como las que hay en otro adam de parís
una en relieve de napoleón bonaparte
pero quizás la que más impacto ha
causado es la que está justamente a mis
espaldas se trata de esta réplica del
guernica de picasso para esta obra se
necesitaron 500 kilogramos de chocolate
y fue fabricada por artesanos
chocolateros de francia y de españa a
ustedes muchas gracias por su sintonía
volvemos en breve con más información
aquí en france 24
[Música]
seguimos aquí en primera plana esta
semana analizando los socios díscolos de
la europea polonia y hungría lo hacemos
con eulalia rubio investigador del
instituto jacques delors la periodista
independiente de elia ron athey y
nuestra corresponsal en bruselas
esther herrera bueno antes de ir a la
pausa hablamos de esa falta de unión del
ya en la unión europea a nivel de que
sanciones aplicar a estos socios
díscolos no sé si la razón fundamental
es de mercado interior las relaciones
comerciales de la locomotora europea de
alemania con polo ni con hungría lo que
ha hasta el momento este tipo
de sanciones ser más contundente
entienden si por supuesto hay un peso
económico en las sanciones porque no se
sabe exactamente cómo van a reaccionar
estos países del este por más que sepan
en mono en este caso estamos tocando el
tema de polonia y hungría pero también
hay un contexto histórico que hay que
tener en cuenta estos son los países del
este vienen de regímenes comunistas hay
países que están más familiarizados con
este tipo de cultura de régimen y pueden
comprender quizás un poco mejor que sea
que haya cierta flexibilidad social con
el tema de la represión a los medios de
la corrupción que pueden tener estos
estos estos líderes en cambio en los
países que no han vivido ese mismo
proceso histórico va a ser opuesto la
comprensión y el entendimiento va a ser
menor por eso es que yo creo que la
estandarización de un pensamiento único
en la unión europea está costando mucho
porque cada país y sobre todo estas
regiones este-oeste tienen ideologías
diferentes no estábamos hablando un poco
antes es importante entender que aparte
de aceptar esas diferencias como como
algo natural pero al mismo tiempo saber
dónde están los límites que tanto uno
puede comprender y cuando en los
regímenes democráticos dejan de serlo no
sé cuál es el pasado comunista de estos
socios del este explican al menos en
parte las derivas autoritarias yo creo
que es lo que decía delia un poco es
importante separar lo que son valores
sociales de lo que son atentados al
estado de derecho
gracia es verdad qué diferencias
este-oeste porque vienen de otro
contexto histórico de tienen otra
historia y siempre en europa hay
divergencias hay heterogeneidad todos
los países no piensan lo mismo sobre
todo los temas sociales por ejemplo hay
países que tendrán legalizado el
matrimonio homosexual luego tendrán
diferentes leyes en temas de aborto y
una cierta heterogeneidad se tiene que
aceptar lo que no se puede aceptar y ahí
donde tenemos que ser serios de donde la
unión europea tiene que ser serio es
cuando hay vulneración al estado de
derecho y a los derechos fundamentales
en términos de discriminación ya que es
muy importante también es importante
igual no caer en la tentación de hablar
siempre del conflicto este-oeste porque
en él o en el este también hay muchos
países que son muy democráticos y que no
tenían ningún problema con la unión
europea como su momento se hizo con el
norte y sur exactamente lo que tenemos
un problema con polonia con hungría
igual con eslovenia también porque
tenemos un primer ministro esloveno con
también un poco con tendencias trump
ianas digamos así pero los otros países
no presentan grandes problemas de países
que tienen problemas de corrupción
importantes en rumanía y bulgaria pero
nos tenemos una
y liberal como la que tenemos en hungría
o en polonia le voy a preguntar a
nuestra corresponsal esther herrera
cuánto recibe en polonia y hungría en
materia de fondos europeos y ayudas por
parte de la unión y cuánto dependen de
ello del fondo de recuperación polonia
tiene pendiente recibir 36 mil millones
de euros en créditos y préstamos y
hungría más de 7 mil millones aparte de
esto hasta el dinero del presupuesto
europeo un día esperar recibir 38 mil
millones de euros en los próximos años y
polonia tiene pendiente en los próximos
años también 140 mil millones de euros
aproximadamente esto hace a ambos ser de
los países que más se benefician del
dinero público europeo si hablábamos
antes de los derechos lgtb pero por
ejemplo en el caso de los derechos
reproductivos de las mujeres también ha
sido un elemento en polonia en polonia
los derechos reproductivos de la mujer
están muy limitados un país donde el
aborto está muy restringido y si por ahí
diferencias en bastantes países también
si miramos a la europa del oeste no es
el mismo no es el mismo régimen en temas
de aborto al que tenemos en irlanda del
que tenemos en españa o en italia o en
alemania es decir una cierta diversidad
la tenemos que aceptar porque europa es
muy distinta lo que no tenemos que
aceptar es cuando esto toca derechos
fundamentales y cuando hay
discriminación por razones de género por
razones de orientación sexual por
razones entonces siempre hay esta visión
siempre hay estas discusiones de que es
aceptable que no es aceptable pero pero
hay cosas que son realmente tocan los
tratados europeos y tocan los derechos
fundamentales y hay otras que hay que
ser tolerantes aunque igual
coincidan con nuestra manera de pensar
estoy de acuerdo con lo que ella dice
también hay que tratar de buscar las
razones de fondo en este momento porque
ésta tiene una crisis demográfica es
decir la población está envejeciendo y
en los nacimientos no compensan que
están actualmente 38 millones de
habitantes en polonia y se calcula que
en 2040 si todo si se mantiene esta esta
predicción van a ser 30 30 millones
entonces ciertas políticas por más que
nos parezcan duras y que atentan la
libertad en este caso de las mujeres
también tienen un contexto nacional que
hay que entender comprender por más que
no sea mismo misma forma que sea en
francia presente por cierto en francia
estos días hemos visto cómo le pen ha
visitado dentro del marco de la
precampaña electoral francesa a viktor
orbán en budapest antes lo hizo el
ultraderechista fémur también se han
convertido una especie viktor orbán en
el baluarte de la extrema derecha quien
debe dar el beneplácito parece que es
muy irónico porque estos dos
contrincantes y pretendientes a la
presencia francesa se presentan como
soberanistas y
yendo a ver a otro presidente de otro
país dar un poco la imagen del goya de
vasallaje casino de ir a buscar como la
unción de del rey de los de extrema
derecha de europeos o sea me parece un
poco contradictorio con una visión
soberanista ir a ver a otro dirigente de
otro país como si necesitaran un poco si
la validación de orbán para presentarse
en francia como los representantes de la
serna derecha parece que le parece de él
y este peregrinaje a parece que es una
búsqueda de legitimación porque orbán
está en el ojo público a partir del 89 y
cuando cayeron los regímenes comunistas
entonces es una figura que por más que
comenzó siendo del centroderecha
representa lo que ellos quieren ser una
extrema derecha fuerte consolidada y que
esté en el poder
no sé qué visión tiene orbán de la gran
hungría que qué es lo que tiene el como
visión de país como como lo enfocarían
yo pienso que es un poco idealizada
y ha tratado de hacer un modelo
nacionalista para reconstruir la
identidad del país
y después de los regímenes comunistas
ultraconservadoras inmigrantes
tradicionales estandarizada yo creo que
no es real para comenzar no es real en
este tiempo es demasiado idealizada para
los conceptos de la extrema derecha por
supuesto pero la ha sabido vender y se
ha mantenido en el poder durante un
largo período diferente tipo de periodos
y por un largo tiempo le voy a preguntar
retirados a este punto a nuestra
corresponsal en bruselas esther herrera
que opciones reales hay de lo que ahora
llamamos el pol exit lab eventual salida
de polonia de la unión europea teniendo
en cuenta sobre todo esa importancia de
lo que recibe polonia de los fondos y
otros factores como el reflejo del
calvario de lo que ha sido el break see
tester
lo cierto es que es muy probable en las
últimas encuestas aproximadamente el 80
por ciento de los polacos se muestra a
favor de estar dentro del bloque es uno
de los mayores porcentajes de la unión
europea además el gobierno polaco
debería pedir la salida y ha dicho que
no lo piensa hacer por otra parte sí que
es cierto que la sentencia del tribunal
supremo que pone en duda la supremacía
del derecho europeo sobre el nacional sí
que deja polonia en una situación rara
porque pertenece a un club pero no
quiere seguir las mismas normas que los
demás y aquí es donde podría decirse que
existe como un pol exit legal de facto
porque polonia tiene un pie dentro y
otro fuera
no sé qué opción es ver el allianz
posible por el éxito legal no habrá como
decía
porque hace falta que el gobierno lo
pida y espero es verdad que algunos
expertos jurídicos que dicen que puede
haber sobre todo caos jurídico también
en polonia porque lo que podemos tener
ahora es algunos jueces polacos que
acatan la decisión del tribunal
constitucional polaco y que que no y que
no reconocen la prima de la primacía del
derecho europeo sobre el derecho polaco
y otros que consideran que no es legal
lo que ha hecho el gobierno en el último
al constitucional político la coca que
hay que hay que repetir que no son un
tribunal constitucional totalmente
independiente y que sigue aplicando la
ley europea o sea nos podemos encontrar
con jueces aplicando diferentes
legislaciones o en polonia se está
viendo el lyon era un lío ese es el
problema que si no se clarifica esto
puede ser problemático en términos de
caos de inseguridad jurídica para los
operadores para la gente en polonia no
sé si de la posible un pool éxito o
visto lo que ha pasado con él ver éxito
en el retrovisor de el calvario que ha
sido y sobre todo teniendo en cuenta lo
que depende el país de los fondos
se aleja s
yo pienso que por el momento no es lo
que polonia quiere ni el gobierno porque
es impopular los polacos la sociedad no
desea salir de la unión europea tomaron
la decisión de ese de esa magnitud sería
estar en contra de una gran masa de
votantes viéndolo un poco más en detalle
yo creo que ahora lo que van a tener que
encontrar es un medio entre el discurso
político que ellos tienen y la realidad
que no quieren salir de la unión europea
yo creo que es lo que pues se puede
rescatar de este tipo de coerción que
está que está siendo bruselas con ellos
es forzar un diálogo el resultado está
por verse
no sé si deben decidir creen que deben
decir los polacos y los húngaros si
deben continuar en el club europeo
ustedes son partidarios de que habría
que preguntar o
de hecho lo que vemos a partir del break
sites en general toda la extrema derecha
la demanda de éxito de flex y alexis ha
desaparecido
también en francia de hecho se han dado
cuenta que no vende océanos por pedir un
éxito porque vemos el reino unido
entonces ha cambiado un poco la
estrategia más bien digamos dinamitaron
europea de dentro o cambiarla de dentro
de los trajes de head más bien intentar
cambiar el modelo de un europea no tanto
salir de la unión europea y todos los
partidos de extrema derecha están un
poco reorientando su estrategia política
en este sentido ya no se habla tanto de
salir sino de hagamos fuerza juntos
vayamos al parlamento europeo juntos y
cambiemos esta unión europea una unión
europea más de naciones más soberanistas
más respetuosa de la soberanía nacional
etcétera es una tendencia de fondo de
nuestra secuencia en este cambio de
estrategia que tiene ahora de la extrema
derecha a partir del break si la extrema
derecha europea que se ve en varios
países la primera aquí mar independent
francia no totalmente había unas se ha
suavizado el tema de salir de la unión
europea porque se ha visto las
consecuencias a corto mediano tiempo
sobre todo ahora con la pandemia del
cobat pero lo que me parece
es importante resaltar que mientras se
están
formulando preguntas y límites dentro de
la unión europea se está tomando mucho
tiempo en ello y se está perdiendo
espacio geopolíticamente porque mientras
estamos discutiendo entre vecinos y
peleándonos entre vecinos no estamos
viendo que está haciendo rusia a eeuu
china y es una es una pena estar
perdiendo entre comillas tiempo en estas
querellas internas cuando realmente el
mundo se está dibujando desdibujando y
dibujando una forma diferente de
bendecir los polacos o los húngaros
deben quedarse yo creo que si les
preguntamos dirán que no quieren irse o
sea esto está clarísimo porque la hemos
visto y en hungría también la mayoría
sigue queriendo quedarse o sea no no
aunque le pidamos al pueblo ellos
surgieran quedarse de hecho esto no no
hay duda
ya lo decía de que los referéndums los
carga el que nunca hay que
preguntar y al menos a los franceses en
un referéndum porque los franceses nunca
responden a lo que se les pregunta
si son países que benefician un montón
de la unión europea a pesar de todo el
mercado único me decía en el presupuesto
europeo si no pues hasta aquí hemos
llegado muchísimas gracias eulalia delia
ya nuestra corresponsal en bruselas
esther herrera ya todos ustedes hasta la
próxima semana aquí en primera plana
gracias